[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing whether or not students at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry are sorted into their
respective houses too early in their
education
and three pupils that were definitely
sorted too young
to start when young witches and wizards
first arrive at the school they are only
11 and can anyone truly say that their
11 year old self was an accurate
representation of the adult they became
perhaps for some but i truly believe
that in most cases the answer would be a
resolute no
so let's dive into that a bit further
for many people muggles and magical
folks alike our younger years serve as a
time to explore experiment and discover
what interests us most in life add to
that the fact that many people in their
youth particularly excitable young
children do many selfish irresponsible
things they'll beg to take part in a
particular activity only to have zero
interest in that same subject just mere
months later throughout this time in our
lives many of us will also have made
plenty of mistakes all in the name of
growing up
so can it really be fair for a magical
sorting hat to look into the minds of
young witches and wizards who have only
lived for just over one decade and
decide which of their characteristics
are most prominent
a decision that will then impact who
their friends are how the wizarding
world will perceive them and ultimately
who they will become
i personally think not
and not to give myself too much credit
but even the great albus dumbledore
asked this very question saying to snape
in the deathly hallows you are a braver
man by far the eagle karkarov you know i
sometimes think we sought too soon he
walked away leaving snape looking
stricken now before we unpack
dumbledore's meaning here let's take a
moment to review the main qualities
associated with each of the four
hogwarts houses gryffindor slytherin
ravenclaw and hufflepuff number one
gryffindor students are sorted into this
highly desirable house of the brave
courageous sort they are often
determined pupils who are known to stand
up for the underdog gryffindors quite
frequently will act first and ask
questions later number two slytherin if
you're sorted into slytherin you're
likely quite clever ambitious and
resourceful although often viewed
through a more negative lens slytherin
house produced both good and bad wizards
throughout the years including the likes
of merlin and most infamously tom riddle
aka voldemort number three ravenclaw
ravenclaw has a reputation as the
smartest group of students in all of
hogwarts witches and wizards who end up
being sorted into this house are
intelligent hungry to learn more and a
little bit eccentric many magical
inventors are known to have come up
through ravenclaw number four hufflepuff
humble hardworking and loyal these are
the characteristics that best describe
many hufflepuff students regrettably and
quite unfittingly this house has been
the butt of many a joke at hogwarts
can't you just hear draco malfoy
sneering about going home rather than
being sorted into hufflepuff that's
likely due to the fact that hufflepuffs
just don't feel the need to brag okay so
now that we've gone over the four houses
and their associated domain traits let's
jump back to that dumbledore quote why
would dumbledore have suggested that
hogwarts may sort their students too
early it's likely pretty obvious right
although snape was many of the things a
typical southern graduate represents
clever resourceful and ambitious i mean
honestly did a wizard ever want the
defense against the dark arts teaching
position more than several snape one of
his more prominent characteristics was
actually courage one of if not the most
defining trait of a gryffindor student
so it stands to reason that a snake grew
up and had more and more need to be
brave as i can't imagine being a double
crossing death eater was too easy on the
nerves although yes that came a little
bit later perhaps a sorting hat would
have recognized his emerging courage the
hat had been put on his head when he was
a little bit older
perhaps as a young teen rather than a
boy of 11 his bravery would have stood
out and overshadowed his other more
slytherin-like qualities hearing
dumbledore say this was of course
devastating for a jaded snape if only he
had been sorted into gryffindor with the
love of his life lily evans would they
have ended up together would she still
be alive
but i digress
alright so if this was the only instance
of a wizard showing qualities from a
rival house as one of their main traits
i don't think i'd be quite as convinced
that hogwarts sorts their students too
early but i do in fact have a couple of
other examples let's take a look most
obvious i would have to say is hermione
yes i believe that the hermione granger
one of harry's absolute best mates in
gryffindor was sorted into the wrong
house think about it how is it possible
that the brightest student in their
entire year was put into gryffindor
rather than ravenclaw
quite honestly she fits the ravenclaw
bill to a t she's brainy she's always
got her head in a book and let's face it
she's more than a little bit odd and as
long as i'm being honest i must say that
i wouldn't exactly categorize her as one
of the most fearless witches that we're
introduced to throughout the series this
is not to diminish any acts of valor
that hermione performs or say that she
isn't brave in certain circumstances but
i definitely think her ravenclaw-like
traits far outweigh her show of courage
or any of the other gryffindor qualities
for example can you honestly recall a
time when hermione didn't want to sit
down and sought out a plan according to
every last detail please she was
ravenclaw through and through this may
have you thinking well maybe the sorting
hat didn't make the greatest decision on
this one and this may have been the case
as she is portrayed as ever prepared and
intelligent beyond compare from the very
beginning of the philosopher's stone
however i would argue that it's possible
that the hat saw certain qualities in
hermione that aligned with multiple
houses just as it did with harry and so
if she'd been given a couple more years
to really come into her own as a bright
young witch it would have been all too
clear to the sorting hat quite
unquestionable really which of her
characteristics were most prominent and
she undoubtedly would have been placed
in ravenclaw alright so if you didn't
like that assessment get ready to be
even more displeased because if i'm
being honest i also don't think that ron
should have been placed in gryffindor
and don't even get me started on his
brother percy to be frank it seems to me
that ron was put into this house simply
because that's where all of the weasleys
ended up and he of course couldn't stand
the thought of not being in gryffindor
which i'm sure the sorting hat took into
consideration once again as it did for
harry when he begged for it not to sort
him into slytherin for the majority of
the weasleys that is bill charlie george
fred and ginny i don't disagree with
their placement in gryffindor but for
much of the series ron was a massive
coward wasn't he he had a terrible fear
of spiders and was even a little
squeamish when it came to playing
quidditch for the gryffindor team you
may be thinking to yourself yes but then
he worked really hard to train up on his
skills and ended up helping gryffindor
win the quidditch tournament in year six
okay yes
but hard work is as you may recall
actually one of hufflepuff's main
qualities along with loyalty and modesty
two more traits that i think more
accurately describe ron than any of the
gryffindor qualities these traditionally
hufflepuff traits of ron's seem to
become clearer and clearer the older one
gets okay not the arachnophobia that
one's there from the beginning but when
he first comes to hogwarts i would argue
that he's not all that sure of what's
most important to him other than the
fact that he simply must be in
gryffindor because all of his family has
been but if he had been sorted later on
i think there's a good chance he would
have ended up in hufflepuff which brings
us to the end of this video what do you
guys think our students at hogwarts
sorted too early do you have any other
examples of witches or wizards who may
have ended up in different houses if the
sorting hat had placed them later on let
me know your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember you could be great you
know it's all here in your head
you